- My first guest,
he's someone who will always hold
a very special place in my heart
because he was the first
person to interview me on TV
after I won American Idol
and he's also my favorite
host of all time.
Take a look.
- I mean, did you think you would win?
Were you that confident?
You can be modest but
you know what I'm saying.
I'm not sure when you
enter these contests,
do you have in the back of your mind,
"I can win this?"
Do you just try to go week to week?
- Very day by day.
I don't like to think too far ahead
or I'll start to stress myself out
but nobody coming into this
thought this show, for one,
I didn't think it was gonna be that huge.
Then nobody thought,
"You're gonna be the winner."
One out of 10,000?
What are the odds?
One out of 10,000.
There you go.
(crowd cheering)
Please welcome the legendary Jay Leno!
(hard rock music)
- Thank you, thank you!
- I'm so excited!
- You know, thank you, thank you.
Thank you very much.
- I'm so excited!
- I've always thought about how you said
the odds of winning are one
in 10,000, what are the odds?
And I said, well the
odds are one in 10,000!
It's a very simple question!
- I at least caught myself
'cause I was like,
"What a dummy."
- What are the odds of that?
Well, they're one in 10,000!
- But wait,
do you hate watching
interviews of yourself
when you're younger?
I don't even do it.
- I don't really watch,
it's like Narcissus staring
at my own reflection.
Once in a while something
comes up I wanna see
an old star or something,
"Oh god, look at them."
I'm not really looking at myself.
Not too much.
- Oh, well that's because you're awesome.
That was crazy, that was 17 years ago.
- Just the fact that you said on TV,
"I'm your first,"
I thought that was surprising.
(Kelly and crowd laugh and cheer)
- It was so great.
All right, well we actually dug up,
because I love you so much, I do,
a weird stalker love, but anyway,
I found a picture from the first day,
since this is the first season for me,
I found a picture of you
hosting for the first time.
Here we go.
Look at you!
(crowd cheers)
My gosh!
So handsome in your suit!
- Yes, yes, so handsome.
- You are handsome!
- Well that's very kind.
- You're my first.
I wouldn't have given it
up if it wasn't handsome.
- That's right, I was your first.
(Kelly and crowd laugh)
- Anybody tuning in right now would go,
"Whoa, I didn't know that!
That's how she got on the show!"
- Yeah!
(Kelly and crowd laugh)
Well when you're good, you're good.
- That's right.
- No, I loved going on your show.
I thought you were just
so much fun and so kind
and you were just my favorite host.
I know I say that and it sounds cliche
'cause you're on my show
but you were always so kind
and you came to everybody's dressing room.
That's my favorite thing about you.
You really invested in people
and it mattered and you cared.
I thought that was really cool.
- Oh, well thanks.
I always like to talk to people.
(crowd claps)
You gave me a bottle of
wine, thank you very much.
- I love wine.
- My mom likes... I'm not a big wine.
My mom,
actually this kind of ties
in with daytime talk shows
'cause my mom had a ritual.
She would watch her story
and then she would watch the Oprah.
Not Oprah.
The Oprah.
- Kind of fits.
- The older my mother got, the more wine.
(Kelly laughs)
So one day I go in the den
and I see the bottle's only
got about this much left
and she's got this glassy look.
My mother was from Scotland and she goes,
"Jamie!
Jamie, I got a question."
"What is it, Mom?"
"I'm watching the Oprah."
She says,
"And the lesbian people,
I don't understand what it is they do
when they get together."
"You know, Mom, this is a
little out of my wheelhouse.
Why don't you get Daddy in here.
Not being a lesbian, I really
can't answer this question."
It's one of those uncomfortable...
My mother, she's got the wine, she goes,
"I don't understand what they do."
"I don't know what they do, Mom!"